hi I'm Brody and you might remember last
year the professor met a man named max
Whitby the element collector he's a guy
who makes real-life periodic tables and
we remember what max told us I'll invite
you to our lab and see something melted
this is quite a test
quite a nice thing to see so I've been
down to London to make a few videos with
Max and well here's the first one where
in the world headquarters of the red
green and blue company RGB research
which is where we make our periodic
tables the displays that we make here
are really mainly for museums and for
schools and occasionally for very
wealthy individuals who fancy a periodic
table in their study and actually what
I'm about to do now is to go and make a
sample to go into one of these periodic
tables this is what we're starting with
and it's a beautiful one kilogram jar of
silver sadly if I bought this about a
year ago I could have got it for maybe
200 pounds but now silver shot up in
price this is one of the terrible
problems of being in the element selling
trade and now this is almost a thousand
pounds worth of silver and what I'm
going to do I hope is to turn it into a
beautiful cylinder this is even more
expensive yeah feel the weight just feel
the way to that yeah well what you're
looking at is pure gold so that's one
kilogram cylinder and if we make an
equivalent sized cylinder and silver
it's going to be about half the weight
it's going to be about half a kilogram
so I'm hoping I can get two cylinders
out of this now the very first step in
making a cylinder do you know what it is
you have to do a risk assessment because
what we're doing is dealing with hot
molten metal and so we've actually gone
through quite carefully thinking of all
the things that can go wrong and brady
we've actually had a chat about that
that's what i'm going to be standing at
here
and I'm going to load the furnace see
that's blowing nicely red hot this is a
graphite crucible in fact stay there I'm
going to turn the light out is that
glowing still yeah so that that is hot
I've set that to 1050 degrees centigrade
so it's quite a bit above the melting
point of silver so I'm going to start by
filling that up and now of course doing
this is going to reduce the temperature
very considerably so once we filled it
up with the pieces of silver we then you
can actually see it cooling and silvers
a superb conductor of heat that's got
you know quite a lot of thermal inertia
you can see that's gone almost now back
to the color of graphite because all the
heat that was in the graphite is gone
into the silver very very quickly
superb conductor and now we're going to
close a little lid and leave it to leave
its cook so
well this is slightly overkill but it
provides a full face mask gloves again
and fingers crossed
fantastic
now that's the sinkhole appearing
hopefully that will fill up the sinkhole
okay well I'm very relieved that seems
to have come out okay spill I'm making
jelly only a thousand degrees Celsius
more now what's going to happen is
that's going to cool down and then we'll
take it to our marvelous engineer David
Brundle and he will machine it down to a
beautiful cylinder 55 millimeters long
and 35 millimeters in diameter and then
it will go to America to a periodic
table